have you ever  had one of those dreams  that feels totally real  [Music]  and once you do wake up wake up  [Music]  it's a total relief  today started pretty good i guess see  you tonight  i love you love you too baby come on  we're late  i hung out with carrie levi and i  conspired about our weekend  and it all went to [ __ ]  that's cymatics patterns created through  vibrational frequencies  third time this year what happened baby  what happened  memories get taken from me sometimes  what the hell where did you go i've been  texting you all night  we can't keep doing this it's not right  there's no choice  if she becomes aware it's only a matter  of time before they become a word you  really made a mess this time  does she know where she came from hi my  name is  aisha if you're  seeing this video it means  well it means that  you